Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie! Happy holidays.
There's some new Star Wars footage all about
Kylo Ren's mission to face the biggest test
of his life I like the way they're presenting
this as if Kylo Ren is the protagonist of
the movie he has to defeat the evil potential
future threats as it is in future Jedi and
if it wasn't clear that is Adam driver underneath
that mast that's not Luke Skywalker and I've
seen some people asked that I felt that was
really clear when they were talking about
their characters way way back in, can't but
her biggest are still some confusion and actually
when they went on Jimmy Kimmel the other night
Kimball asked Adam driver do we get to see
you with your mask off in Adam driver looks
at JJ Abrams is like I don't I don't know
if I'm allowed to say reading between the
lines of course he wouldn't of said that if
he wasn't going to take his mask off you just
be like nope don't take mask off I look like
that the entire movie so I don't necessarily
that he scored in the way that Darth Vader
was scarred like Darth Vader's technology
kept him alive we don't know if that's the
same things going on with Kylo Ren or if he's
wearing it more for show we do know that any
circuses character supreme leader's note does
kind of exist in that state he's been grievously
harmed and left very vulnerable so so he probably
has to say in some sort of Vader type chamber
but if it wasn't cleared that is who is speaking
to Kylo Ren it's kinda hard to distinguish
between the voices is certain point in the
clip but it's any circuses character telling
Adam driver's character Kylo Ren that you're
going to be facing the biggest test of your
life these characters here standing with Kylo
Ren with you know it is raining down do look
like their special I don't know if these are
the nights of rent because that's where Kylo
Ren got his name from that's not actually
his real name he took that name later in life
I think at some point during the movie will
find out why that is and will find out about
what happened with the nights of rent why
he chose the dark side of the force this is
also kind of like a dark side to user and
everybody still wondering where Luke Skywalker
is because the like is he going to be evil
and the movie is that why that I showing them
JJ Abrams actually explained that them not
showing him in the marketing like the trailers
the step before the movie is a conscious choice
to tie in thematically with what's going on
with Luke inside the movie itself if you guys
and see a couple weeks ago I posted this Luke
Skywalker video right can explain what JJ
Abrams said about Luke's role in the film
in the time since return of the Jedi the big
force users like Luke Skywalker Darth Vader
they been turned into Ms. and because a bunch
of people in the Empire led by supreme leader's
note have formed the first order obviously
the more evil characters control propaganda
in the galaxy so they been selling everyone
this alternative narrative where the Empire
were the heroes of the original trilogy Luke
Skywalker was the villain who destroyed bad
as you can see why Luke might hide out after
that the entire galaxy wants his blood when
you look at fins character he kind of serves
as the awakening like oh my God I been told
a lie this whole time he awakens to the truth
as well as awakening to the force. They actually
said a little about it at Comic Con, Adam
Driver was like you know sometimes the best
villains don't think of themselves as evil
even David Tennant who's the the purple man
during Jessica Jones killgrave he went on
late night with Seth Myers and was talking
about how his villain doesn't think of himself
as a villain either is like how many villains
actually think of themselves as villains Donald
Trump doesn't think of himself is a villain
which is like a funny David Tennant joke but
just think about that idea when you go to
see the movie Kylo Ren thinks he's doing the
right thing the dark side is the right path
for the galaxy is not trying to subjugate
people out of malice he just feels like the
Jedi have really bad ideas and he wants to
stomp that out here's my big question if you
guys let me know in the comments who is your
favorite character from the Star Wars universe
that's a villain it doesn't think of themselves
as a villain I about the pry Darth Vader would
be most people's pic like he does not think
he is evil owned by the way even though all
the teaser clips still say this film is not
yet rated the film is actually been rated
PG-13 is in a couple jokes is that all was
only can make 17 good jillion dollars now
really that the PG-13 versus PG rating just
allows them to push it a little bit harder
if you remember episode three revenge of the
Sith was rated PG-13 so just expect something
on par with that in terms of violent like
this the stuff they show if you do have young
children I don't do the big if you have young
children please do not deprive them of the
pleasure of seeing Star Wars in the theater
you know PG-13 I think will be totally fine
for everyone what's can happen next is I'm
in a post another Jessica Jones video be like
another block of four episodes if you guys
haven't been watching it it is awesome you
need to check it out there's also some other
flash arrow stuff and then there's a Shannara
video that I'm in be doing pretty soon to
so be sure to subscribe to get everything
and I should say there's also some big Doctor
strange new so I'll probably be doing at Doctor
strange video sometime during this weekend
so much awesome stuff happening this week
is like the best holiday week ever while you
guys wait for everything to post you can click
here for the Captain America Civil War trailer
to watch it like 18 billion more times and
you can click here for all the other Star
Wars videos that I've been posting and you
so much for watching everybody let's high
five and I'll see you guys tonight!